So now for the answer.
What we need is an input in which quotes are contained within the tag.
For instance, this could be an input like less than,
double quote, double quote, and greater than.
If we go through the program, we would see that tag would be set,
then quote would be set, then quote would be unset,
and then tag would be unset.
The output would be empty, and therefore would not contain any HTML markup.
Note, though, that this line would be executed
and therefore also appear in the coverage.
And then we can simply say that execution of this line
directly is related to passing or failing.
So when given an arbitrary program, it is unlikely
that we will find lines that are only executed when the program fails.
And anyway, such lines would be found by the 1st test that executes them.
And we are pretty good at testing, aren't we?
What we want to look for are lines that statistically correlate with failure.
That is, they may occasionally pass,
but by and large, they more frequently fail than pass.